Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we talk about amazing research
papers.
However, when a paper is published, also,
a talk often has to be given at a conference.
And this paper is about the talk itself, or
more precisely, how to enhance your presentation
with dynamic graphics.
Now, these effects can be added to music videos
and documentary movies, however, they take
a long time and cost a fortune.
But not these ones, because this paper proposes
a simple framework in which the presenter
stands before a kinect camera and an AR mirror
monitor, and can trigger these cool little
graphical elements with simple gestures.
A key part of the paper is the description
of a user interface where we can design these
mappings.
This skeleton represents the presenter who
is tracked by the kinect camera, and as you
see here, we can define interactions between
these elements and the presenter, such as
grabbing this umbrella, pull up a chart, and
more.
As you see with the examples here, using such
a system leads to more immersive storytelling,
and note that again, this is an early implementation
of this really cool idea.
A few more papers down the line, I can imagine
rotatable and deformable 3D models and photorealistic
rendering entering the scene…well, sign
me up for that.
If you have any creative ideas as to how this
could be used or improved, make sure to leave
a comment.
In the meantime, we are also now available
on Instagram, so if you wish to see cool little
snippets of our latest episodes, including
this one, make sure to check us out there.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!